ميدانيا ايضا قالت سلطته المواليه لروسيا
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول اختراق
الدفاعات في محيط مدينه بخموت وعرقله تقدم
الوحدات الروسيه ونقلت وكاله عن السلطات
في قوه العدو تحاول منع القوات الروسيه من
تنفيذ عمليات هجوميه واضافت ان القوات
الروسيه تتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه لمنع اي
اختراق وتقليل القصف على
كشفت السلطات المواليه لروسيا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تستخدم الحقول في المنطقه
لايصال تعزيزات بعد نجاح القوات الروسيه
في قطع خطوط امدادها في وقت سابق
واخر التحديثات من الجانب الروسي حول تطور
المعارك وما الذي يحدث تحديدا في محيط
نعم سهام في محيط بخموت تقول القوات
الروسيه انها تصد كل الهجمات التي تقوم
بها القوات الاوكرانيه في هذه المدينه
التي كانت قد اعلنت السيطره عليها في
العشرين من ايار مايو الماضي تتركز هذه
الهجمات من شمال مدينه باخموت ومن جنوبها
في محاوله للقوات الاوكرانيه لاختراق
تحصينات للقوات الروسيه في تلك المدينه
ولكن وفق التحديثات التي تنشرها وزاره
الدفاع فان كل هذه الهجمات تقوم القوات
الروسيه بصدها ولكن قبل قليل وزاره الدفاع
تحدثت عن احدى المعارك التي وصفت في
الايام الماضيه بانها بالاكثر سخونه عند
هذا التقاطع بين بين مقاطعه دانيتسكو
ومقاطعه
الدفاع عن صد خمس هجمات من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه وعن الحاق خسائر كبيره في صفوف
المقاتلين وايضا في العتاد الاوكراني هذا
مرتبط بعدد من الجبهات
فيزاولوجيا اوريخوف ايضا عليها وفيها
معارك داريا بين القوات الروسيه والقوات
الاوكرانيه وهذا الامر يمتد وهذه المعارك
تمتد الى مقاطعه وبالتحديد جنوب هذه
المقاطعه نتحدث هنا عن جبهه مارينكا وجبهه
تقول القوات الروسيه انها عززت مواقعها في
في جبهه اوغليدار وايضا هناك حديث من قبل
القوات الروسيه وايضا من قبل قوات احمد
الشيشانيه التي تقاتل على تلك الجبهه
بانها تحوس على مواقع استراتيجيه ومهمه في
في جبهه مارينكا بالتحديد وهذا الامر تحدث
عنه الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان قادروف حين وعد
اهالي منطقه بيتروسكي في داخل مدينه
دانيتك الذين يتم او تصل اليهم القذائف
الاوكرانيه بشكل مكثف في الايام الماضيه
وعدهم بان هذا الامر سينتهي في القريب
العاجل اذا ما الى مدينه دنيتك وبالتحديد
الى شمال مدينه دنيتك عند جبهه افديفيكا
المعارك صعبه للغايه ولكن ما تقوم به
القوات الروسيه هو محاوله الاختراق
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه في تلك الجبهه اليوم
القراءه العسكريه من قبل المحللين
العسكريين الروس يقولون ان محاوله القيام
به اوكرانيا في الفتره الماضيه لناحيه شق
او مد طريق او خط من جنوب دانيات وصولا
الى وصولا الى مريول الواقعه على بحر ازوف
باء بالفشل وانتهى الامر الى مناوشات
وقتال عند هذه المنطقه الرماديه التي توصف
بالرماديه في المنطقه الماضيه في المنطقه
الواقعه بين سيطره القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيا وبات العنوان السيطره على
قريه مكروفكا المنطقه